well Greg Eric gentlemen congratulations
you're moving forward in the third and
final round of this competition you get
four days of your home forges to build
another iconic weapon from the wild west
gentlemen we want you to build this
this is the Vaquero machete
the Vaquero machete became widely
popular with the original Cowboys of the
Southwest during the 20th century
featuring a thin slightly curved blade
the weapon was much lighter and easier
to carry than the larger machetes
previously used by the Cowboys making it
ideal to deliver damaging slashes and
chops on everything from brush to
enemies on the great Frontier
the rich history and culture of the
Cowboys who carry this weapon can be
found on display at the Bullock Museum
in Austin Texas so good luck we will see
you in four days
[Music]
my name is Gregory McClure I am 50 years
old I'm from Tacoma Oklahoma knife
making has always been a deep-seated
passion my grandfather pulled me in when
I was 10 years old we found a piece of
metal alongside the road and ever since
then I started making custom knives all
right she is cooking like a June bride
okay
straight buddy everything's coming out
nicely
it's like it's supposed to
the gas Foundry is what I'm going to be
making the guard and the pommel out of
[Music]
carved the exact thing you want to cast
out of foam this is what it will look
like when we get done then you pack it
in green sand here we go you ready
and as you pour the molten metal on it
it evaporates the foam and leaves you
with the shape that you're desired that
was good guys
that's exciting after a little bit of
sanding it looked great
[Music]
the one thing you need to worry about
with this kind of handle is not giving
your pieces glued well enough my
competition is going to be good but at
the end of the day he's going to bring
his best I brought my best we'll see
what happens
if that'll work
[Music]
my name is Eric Finch I'm 20 years old
from Harmony Pennsylvania and I'm
bladesmithing for almost three years
when I first got into blade smithing I
didn't have a lot of money and my uncle
Chuck he was super supportive he got me
my first and will he really had a lot of
faith in me getting into this and so
being here it feels like it's uh finally
rewarding him for what he's done for me
my game plan is to start with Damascus
I'm going to start out with 20 pieces
shooting for a 60 to 70 layer in the end
so I got my Billet swelled it up in the
Forge last night got it quenched and
then the temper
for today thinking about starting
working on the palm oil when I knew my
dad my brother out hunting with the
Hawks I had him stop over so that would
get a nice look at a 3D bird my dad's
been a falconer since before I was born
so I've always had Hawks my entire life
it's very lucky that I'm able to
incorporate this because that way I can
do a direct comparison I'm getting ready
to go into gluing the handle
and then once to get all the cleanup
finished pretty much all I have to do is
add an edge and it'll be done
and I'm really proud of how this looks
howdy Partners welcome to the Keel test
your Vaquero machetes look beautiful but
how lethal are they to find that out I'm
going to take care of machetes to
deliver some lethal blows on this big
carcass Greg you feel lucky oh very
lucky all right let's do this
foreign
Greg the leather wrapping that you have
here is nice and smooth the handle is oh
void the one thing though that's just a
lot of handle and because you have a
smooth handle right here a couple of
times my hand just slid down
but your edges are sharp those are razor
sharp Cuts well we're all sorry you will
kill thank you Doug
Eric your turn are you ready let's do it
let's do this
okay
good job buddy that's it
all right Eric let's talk about your
Vaquero machete here what I like about
it is that it just fits my hand
perfectly so it's locked in there now
your Edge that's a Chevron right there
all the way up those are very sharp deep
Cuts even on thrusting overall sir
it will Keel into here
Oliver carols Welcome to our strength
test the fence board and skull chop
all right Greg you're up first you ready
yes sir
Greg right off blade held up beautifully
this thing is just the sharpest one I
started feels like a great fighter to me
only complaint I have is that long
handle but other than that the Artistry
is really well done
that's a joy to use nicely done thank
you
Eric you ready let's do it all right
all right so first off Eric very
different grind on this edge with that
secondary bevel but it's wicked sharp
and it's still sharp held up fine didn't
lose any blade at all no rolls no chips
nothing but still as straight as when I
started good job awesome thank you
eight Spitz welcome
the Gunslinger slice
[Music]
Greg you up first you ready for this
absolutely all right
foreign
Greg
nicely done those are very sharp clean
cuts on I'd say at least three layers of
clothing your weapon
it will cut thank you
Eric your turn sir ready let's do it
let's do this
[Music]
all right Eric the edges are sharp
enough to cut through all layers and
expose some of the blood overall sir
your weapon you'll cut thank you
all right gentlemen well I gotta say
both of you impressed us from the very
beginning of this competition the first
two rounds you guys crushed it but this
competition as you know only one of you
can leave here as a fortune fire
champion and receive that check for ten
thousand dollars
the fortune fire Champion is
thank you
Eric congratulations you did it well
Greg I hope you had as much fun working
here as we had watching you that is an
unbelievably stunning piece but
unfortunately every time this
competition has ended I want to say
thank you for coming but at this point
in time I have to ask you to please step
off the fourth floor thank you
camera
I have no shame coming in second to this
young man the check would have been nice
the title would have been nicer but
remember I'm still the fastest blade in
the West
well Eric you are the fortune fire
Champion you're receiving a check for
ten thousand dollars congratulations
[Applause]
never thought I'd be here at this young
I don't even know how to react it feels
surreal from start to finish it's been a
crazy crazy competition and my uncle it
was probably my biggest driver to Win It
uncle Chuck this is for you
foreign